Voici comment ça fonctionnait.
Vous lui posiez une question en vous mettant à genoux.
Ensuite, elle entrait en une transe qui pouvait prendre un ou deux jours.
Puis, finalement, elle en sortait
pour vous donner ses prédictions comme réponse.
Depuis les os divinatoires de la Chine ancienne
à la Grèce antique et les calendriers mayas,
les gens ont cherché avec passion dans les prédictions
le moyen de savoir ce qui allait se passer dans le futur.
Et c'est parce que nous voulons tous prendre la bonne décision.
Nous ne voulons pas manquer le coche.
Le futur est effrayant
mais devient plus engageant quand nous savons
que nous pouvons prendre une décision avec une garantie du résultat.
Hé bien, nous avons un nouvel oracle, et son nom, c'est « Big Data »,
ou « Watson », « apprentissage profond » « réseau de neurones artificiel »...
Voici le genre de questions posées aujourd'hui à notre oracle :
« Quel est le moyen le plus efficace
d'expédier ces téléphones de la Chine à la Suède ? »,
ou « Quels sont les risques
que mon enfant naisse avec une maladie génétique ? »
ou « Quel volume de ventes pouvons-nous prévoir pour ce produit ? »
J'ai un chien. Son nom est Elle et elle déteste la pluie.
J'ai tout essayé pour tenter de changer son attitude.
Mais vu que j'ai échoué,
je suis obligée de consulter, moi aussi, un oracle appelé Dark Sky,
chaque fois que nous allons sortir pour la promenade,
pour les prévisions météo précises des prochaines dix minutes.
Elle est si mignonne.
À cause de tout cela, notre oracle est une industrie de 122 milliards de dollars.
Mais malgré la taille de cette industrie,
les retours sont étonnamment faibles.
Il est facile d'investir dans big data, mais l'utiliser est difficile.
Plus de 73 % des projets de big data ne sont pas rentables,
et certains dirigeants viennent me voir en disant :
« Il nous est arrivé la même chose.
Nous avons investi dans le big data,
mais nos employés ne prennent pas de meilleures décisions,
et ils ne vont certainement pas trouver plus d'idées révolutionnaires. »
Pour moi, tout ceci est vraiment intéressant
parce que je suis un ethnographe de la technologie.
J'étudie et je conseille les entreprises
sur les modèles d'utilisation de la technologie,
et un de mes centres d'intérêt est la data.
Pourquoi plus de données ne nous aide pas à prendre de meilleures décisions,
en particulier pour les sociétés qui ont les ressources
pour investir dans ces systèmes de big data ?
Pourquoi cela n'est-il pas plus facile pour eux?
J'a moi-même fait l'expérience de ce problème.
En 2009, j'ai commencé un travail de recherche à Nokia.
À cette époque, Nokia était une des plus grandes compagnies
de téléphones mobiles dans le monde,
dominant les marchés naissants en Chine, au Mexique et en Inde,
pays dans lesquels j'avais déjà fait des recherches
sur la façon dont les gens à faible revenu utilisent la technologie.
J'ai passé beaucoup de temps libre en Chine,
ce qui m'a permis de découvrir l'économie parallèle.
J'ai, par exemple, travaillé comme vendeuse de rue
en vendant des raviolis chinois aux ouvriers du bâtiment.
J'ai travaillé sur le terrain,
passant des jours et des nuits dans les cybercafés,
fréquentant la jeunesse chinoise pour comprendre
la façon dont ils utilisent les jeux et les portables
y compris dans leurs déplacements de la campagne à la ville.
En compilant toutes ces expériences qualitatives,
j'ai commencé à voir très clairement
qu'un très grand changement allait se produire
parmi les chinois à faible revenu.
Bien que cernés par les publicités pour des produits de luxe
tels que les toilettes chics - qui n'en voudrait pas ? -
pour des appartements et des voitures,
à travers mes conversations avec eux,
j'ai découvert que les pubs qui les affectaient le plus
étaient celles concernant les IPhones
qui leur promettaient l'accès à une vie à la pointe de la technologie.
Quand j'ai vécu avec eux dans des bidonvilles urbains comme celui-ci,
j'ai vu des gens investir presque la moitié de leur revenu
dans l'achat d'un téléphone, lequel devenait de plus en plus « shanzhaï »,
une imitation bon marché d'iPhone et autres marques.
Ils sont tout à fait utilisables.
Ils font l'affaire.
Après des années à vivre et travailler avec les ambulants,
à travailler et faire tout ce qu'ils faisaient,
j'ai commencé à joindre toutes ces données ensemble -
des choses à priori insignifiantes comme la vente de raviolis chinois
aux choses plus consistantes comme le montant de leurs factures de téléphone.
J'ai été capable de créer une image plus globale de ce qui se passait.
Alors, je me suis rendue compte
que même le plus pauvre, en Chine, souhaiterait avoir un smartphone
et qu'il serait prêt à tout faire pour en avoir un.
Rappelez-vous que les iPhone venaient juste de sortir.
C'était en 2009, il y a huit ans,
et les Androïde ressemblaient à peine aux iPhone.
Beaucoup de gens intelligents et réalistes ont dit :
« Ces smartphones sont juste une mode.
Qui veut porter ces trucs lourds
dont les batteries sont faciles à épuiser et qui se cassent en tombant ? »
Mais j'avais beaucoup de données et confiance en mes intuitions.
J'étais donc très impatiente de les partager avec Nokia.
Mais Nokia n'a pas été convaincu parce que ce n'était pas du big data.
Ils ont dit : « Nous avons des millions de points de données
et rien n'indique que quelqu'un veut acheter un smartphone.
Vos données basées sur 100, bien que larges,
sont trop faibles pour que nous les prenions réellement au sérieux. »
J'ai dit : « Vous avez raison.
Vous n'êtes pas capable de le voir car vos enquêtes assument
que les gens ne connaissent pas les smartphones.
Vous ne pouvez donc pas obtenir les données
concernant le désir des gens d'acheter un smartphone dans deux ans.
Vos méthodes ont été conçues pour optimiser un modèle commercial existant.
Pour ma part, j’observe les nouvelles dynamiques humaines
qui ne sont pas encore apparues.
Nous explorons en dehors de la dynamique des marchés afin de la prédire. »
Savez-vous ce qui est arrivé à Nokia ?
Leur compagnie a subit un revers.
Ceci est le prix à payer pour avoir raté le coche.
C'était inconcevable!
Mais Nokia n’est pas la seule.
Je vois sans arrêt des organisations rejeter des données
quand elles ne viennent pas d'une analyse quantitative
ou ne s'accordent pas avec une.
Ce n'est pas la faute du big data.
C'est la façon dont nous utilisons big data ; c'est notre responsabilité.
La réputation de succès de big data
vient de la quantification d'environnements bien spécifiques
tels que les réseaux de distribution d’électricité,
la logistique de livraison ou le code génétique,
où nous quantifions en systèmes plus ou moins indépendants.
Mais tous les systèmes ne sont pas aussi indépendants.
Lorsque les systèmes sont plus dynamiques,
en particulier ceux impliquant des êtres humains,
les forces sont complexes et imprévisibles,
et nous ne savons pas bien les modéliser.
Quand vous prédisez un comportement humain,
de nouveaux facteurs entrent en jeu car les conditions changent constamment.
Donc, ce cycle est infini.
Quand vous pensez savoir, quelque chose d'inconnu apparaît.
C'est pourquoi compter uniquement sur big data
augmente nos risques de rater le coche
tout en nous donnant l'illusion que nous savons déjà tout.
Ce qui rend ce paradoxe si difficile à voir
ou même à l'appréhender avec notre intellect,
c'est ce que j'appelle « le préjugé de la quantification »,
l'habitude inconsciente de privilégier le mesurable sur le non-mesurable -
nous en faisons souvent l'expérience au travail ;
certains de nos collèges peuvent être comme ça
voir notre compagnie toute entière -
où les gens deviennent si focalisés sur ce chiffre
qu'ils ne peuvent rien voir en dehors,
même si vous leur présentez les preuves sous les yeux.
C'est un message intéressant
parce qu'il n'y a rien de mal à quantifier.
En fait, c'est très gratifiant.
Regarder une feuille de calcul Excel me réconforte beaucoup,
même les plus simples.
(Rires)
C'est un peu comme si oui, la formule marche,
tout va bien, la situation est sous contrôle.
Mais le problème, c'est que quantifier devient une addiction,
et quand nous oublions cela et n'avons rien pour nous le rappeler,
il est facile de rejeter les données
qui ne peuvent être exprimées en valeurs numériques ;
il est facile de déraper vers le raisonnement miracle
comme s'il existait une solution simple.
C'est un dangereux moment pour toute organisation
car souvent, le futur que nous avons besoin de prédire
n'est pas dans cette botte de foin, là,
mais plutôt dans cette tornade qui se dirige sur nous,
en dehors de la grange.
Il n'y a pas de plus grand danger que d'être incapable de voir l'inconnu.
Cela vous conduit à prendre de mauvaises décisions
et à manquer quelque chose d'important.
Néanmoins cette voie n'est pas une fatalité.
Il s'avère que l'oracle de la Grèce antique
contient la clé secrète qui montre la voie à suivre.
Des recherches géologiques récentes ont montré
que le Temple d'Apollon dans lequel était situé le fameux oracle
a été construit entre deux failles sismiques.
Ces failles libéraient des vapeurs pétrochimiques
du dessous de l'écorce terrestre,
et l'oracle était littéralement assise au-dessus de ces deux failles
et inhalait des quantités énormes d'éthylène...
(Rires)
C'est vrai !
C'est vrai et c'est ce qui lui permettait de pérorer et halluciner
et d'entrer dans un état similaire à la transe.
Elle planait complètement !
(Rires)
Donc, comment se fait-il que les gens
obtenaient des conseils utiles dans son état ?
Eh bien, voyez-vous ces gens autour de l'oracle ?
Ils la soutiennent car elle est un peu dans les vapes.
Remarquez cet homme sur la gauche qui tient le carnet orange.
Ce sont les guides du temple
qui travaillent main dans la main avec l'oracle.
Quand les questionneurs venaient et s'agenouillaient,
les guides du temple se mettaient au travail,
car une fois les questions posées, ils observaient les états émotionnels
et demandaient des infos complémentaires :
« Pourquoi voulez-vous cette prédiction ? Qui êtes-vous ?
Qu'allez-vous faire de cette information ? »
Ensuite, les guides du temple,
avec cette information plus ethnographique et qualitative,
interprétaient les paroles de l'oracle.
Donc, l'oracle n'était pas seule,
de même, nos systèmes de big data ne devraient pas l'être.
Pour clarifier, je ne dis pas
que les systèmes de big data exhalent de l'éthylène
ou qu'ils font des prévisions caduques.
Exactement le contraire, ce que je veux dire
c'est que tout comme l'oracle avait besoin des guides du temple,
nos systèmes de big data ont aussi besoin d'eux.
Ils ont besoin des ethnographes et des chercheurs sur les utilisateurs
pour rassembler ce que j'appelle « les données denses ».
Ce sont des données précieuses fournies par les hommes,
les histoires, émotions et interactions non quantifiables.
C'est le genre de données que j'ai recueillies pour Nokia
sous la forme d'un échantillon très petit
mais incroyablement profond quant au sens.
Ce qui le rend si dense et consistant,
c'est l'expérience et la compréhension du récit humain.
C'est ce qui aide à percevoir ce qui manque dans nos modèles.
Les données denses ancrent les questions commerciales
dans les questions humaines.
C'est pourquoi fusionner big data et données denses
permet d'obtenir une image plus complète.
Le big data peut offrir des aperçus à échelle
et tirer le meilleur profit de l'intelligence artificielle,
tandis que les données denses aident à minimiser
la perte de contexte générée en rendant big data utilisable,
et à tirer le meilleur de l'intelligence humaine.
En fait, quand vous intégrez les deux, ça devient vraiment intéressant,
car vous ne travaillez plus uniquement avec les données recueillies,
vous travaillez avec des données non recueillies.
Vous commencez à demander « pourquoi? » :
Pourquoi cela se passe-t-il ?
Quand Netflix a fait ça,
ils ont ouvert une nouvelle voie de transformation pour leur entreprise.
Netflix est connue pour ses algorithmes de recommandation.
Ils ont offert un million de dollars à quiconque pouvait les améliorer
et il y a eu des gagnants.
Mais Netflix a découvert que ces améliorations
étaient seulement incrémentielles.
Pour comprendre la situation,
ils ont embauché un ethnographe, Grant McCracken,
afin d'obtenir des données denses,
et il a trouvé une chose qu'ils n'avaient pas vue à l'origine
dans les données quantitatives.
Il a découvert que les gens aimaient le « binge-watching ».
En fait, ils ne s'en culpabilisaient pas mais en jouissaient.
Netflix a réalisé : « Oh, c'est une nouvelle donnée ».
Ils se sont tournés vers leur équipe de science des données
qui a su comparer cette donnée avec leurs données quantitatives.
Après l'avoir vérifiée et validée,
Netflix a décidé d'agir de façon simple mais efficace.
Au lieu d'offrir une même émission dans différents genres
ou plus d'émissions différentes d'utilisateurs similaires,
ils ont simplement offert plus de la même émission.
« Nous vous rendons le Binge-watching plus facile! »
Ils ne se sont pas arrêtés là mais ont fait toutes sortes de choses
pour changer l’entière expérience de leur spectateur
pour l'encourager au binge-watching.
Voilà pourquoi les gens et les amis disparaissent des weekends entiers
pour regarder les « Master of None » manqués.
En fusionnant big data et données denses, ils ont amélioré leurs services
et transformé la façon dont nous consommons les médias.
Maintenant, il est prévu que leurs stocks doublent dans les prochaines années.
Mais il ne s'agit pas de regarder plus de vidéos,
ou de vendre plus de smartphones.
Pour certains, incorporer le résultat des données denses dans cet algorithme
peut être une question de vie ou de mort,
en particulier pour les marginalisés.
Les services de Police, dans tout le pays,
utilisent le big data dans la prévision policière,
afin de définir les cautions et recommandations de sentences
d'une manière qui renforce les préjugés existants.
Skynet, l'algorithme d'apprentissage machine de la NASA
a probablement aidé à tuer des milliers de civils au Pakistan
en mal interprétant les métadonnées des appareils cellulaires.
Quand nos vies deviennent de plus en plus automatisées,
des automobiles aux assurances maladie et à l'emploi,
il est probable que nous tous
allons être affectés par les erreurs de quantification.
Mais la bonne nouvelle, c'est que nous avons fait des progrès
depuis les émanations d'éthylène de la prophétie.
Nous avons de meilleurs outils, donc utilisons-les au mieux.
Intégrons big data aux données denses.
Amenons nos guides du temple avec les oracles.
Et que ce soit dans les entreprises, les sociétés à but non lucratif,
les gouvernements ou même les logiciels,
tout ce travail compte,
car il implique que tous ensemble, nous nous engageons
à créer des données meilleures,
de meilleurs algorithmes, résultats, et de meilleures décisions.
C'est de cette façon que nous éviterons de manquer le coche.
(Applaudissements)